hi I'm Heidi Klum whether you're on a
mission to see some of Europe's finest
art sample cutting-edge cuisine or
simply just soak up the cultural
ambiance France can seduce you with it
all
packy known as the city of lights
and the city of lovers one of the best
things to do in the city plunk yourself
down in a cafe and while away an
afternoon sipping on cafe and people
watching the best way to see Paris is on
foot
skip the metro put on a good pair of
walking shoes and check out the sights
from the Arc de Triomphe stroll down the
Shawn Tuesday at the grand and the c-pen
a to the plus Philip huncle for a change
of pace get your art fix at the Boone
and the poppy du centre cross the river
sand and torn up Adam Cathedral once on
the left bank visit the Sorbonne before
heading westward to lase Anthony and
finishing at the Eiffel Tower but Paris
could should be the first stop on your
personal tour de france cruise westward
down the guava Valley its Renaissance
era shadows and palaces seem straight
out of a fairy tale for another magical
ride take a train to the Normandy coast
at mole Sam Shen rising from its rocky
shores the thirteen hundred year old
Benedictine abbey at low tide is
connected to the land but as the tide
rises it transforms into an island over
the years it served as a monastery
fortress prison and today one of
France's top tourist draws
the South of France is famous for its
Riviera beaches and Jets and resorts but
that overlooks the area's many other
charms for taste of opulence see Ivan
owns papal palaces or take a
sweet-smelling tour of the historic
perfume factories of class if you're
interested in thai cuisine you can try
your hand at hunting for truffles a
pungent fungus cherished by the world's
great chefs and sometimes worth more per
ounce than gold or of course you might
simply relax and enjoy the beautiful
countryside
France is a traveler's delight in any
season
packed with pleasures for historians
nature lovers artists and urbanites
alike both wash